all right Alfred Alfred you're the
pastor at new st. John Baptist Church of
Houma yes in Houma Louisiana yes this is
a this is the heart of Cajun country
right right you you grew up where I grew
up in fact oh right across the Bayou
from the church and the plantation was
called pres and he still called press
Tia ah so you've been here your whole
life
hallelujah um 6161 and you grew up with
both your parents yes I did good
childhood yes and you became a man of
faith and a religious leader at what
point in your life oh it was 2006 your
you were raised with the Baptist
background yes and in 2006 you became a
pastor I became a past in 2006
so what do you see what's going on in
our in our country with the all the race
issues that are in the in the news right
now black lives matter what happened up
in Minnesota a while back what do you
but what do you make of it and what is
your congregation think of all this
well to me it seems like all what's been
going on no change is being made it
still happening
and what is the reason why this still
going on and it's been going on kind of
regular for a short period of time you
know it's not space it's like every two
weeks or something like that something
like that happening so I'm wondering why
disallowing to be well this can be
slowed down or stopped you know they
protesting but look like the protests
are not doing too much of a good the
approach testing behind these things
that's happening so where we go from
here with this year when it's there to
happening no I don't I don't like
chicken no sighs but I like
righteousness not taking no sighs
because of you know whatever your
nationality may be but I like justice in
the right way
to me I think there's not enough
discipline with the police force they're
not using enough discipline with the
policeman's and the actions that they
take when they're doing stuff like that
and I've sprinkled as one get by the
other one believe that they can get by
doing it wrong
- and long as they continue not using
the discipline that they need to use I
believe that it's not gonna stop you
grew up in the south do you do you see
how racism has as a diminished has it
increased has it changed since you were
a kid
Oh back in my childhood days at that
time it wasn't as bad and I'm not
talking about the slavery time I'm
talking about in my childhood time there
was segregation yeah it wasn't that bad
well you had police protective you know
like it is now but right now a lot had
changed from my time from my childhood
when it come down to the law itself not
just police brutality the law itself a
lot of changes have taken place to where
just did not just being revealed in a
way that is sure
so do you think racism has increased or
decreased or changed and maybe maybe
it's still around
they have increase do you think is
increased hey hey hey things are pretty
better than me not gonna success me in
one way they have me Cruise in another
way happen yeah because in the sixties
it was extreme how blacks were kept
totally separate right so now I'm saying
the one we have in another way yeah what
do you see the church's role in in all
this I mean what do you do you think
religion can help lead either the white
part of our population or the lack or
all of our population into something
healthier and something better where
we're treating each other better and
more fairly what I know to the black
denomination Baptist
it's like you can tell them what to do
and how to go about doing this where it
will be better and some tests don't take
no he turret and he fall back on the
church like the church not doing nothing
but the church it's not doing what they
should be doing I can change that but
we're not doing what we what we really
should be doing all of the things we
should be doing but we're doing I think
we're doing enough there's some are
there circle be increased still oh I
mean be decreased did an increase of
what's going on right now you know but
the people got to do their part to to
make it work we got to work together to
make this thing come together like it
should be you got to work together you
just can't expect one side to to do this
and then the other side not even trying
to get on one a call with the other side
I believe we come together it'll be so
much better and like I say I I'm not a
racist I don't care what color your
yield all of my body justice yes he I
just came from Mississippi and and also
here in in parts of Louisiana there is
some very poor communities some of the
poorest in the country and those are
primarily african-american communities
well that's why I had see what I said
about the black Baptist denomination the
Baptist religious it's not that
the pastor the preacher is not chutney
idea phone is just that they not
accepting it if I tell you how to go by
doing this what to do how to go by doing
like I said I was telling somebody other
day if you know that all this brutality
is increasing don't put yourself in the
way of it try not to put yourself in the
way of it see all we look at what the
policemen are did was we're now looking
at what caused it to be Oh
for example if I don't know dealing with
the policeman with the law i'ma try to
not break the law so they don't have to
I don't have to deal with them you see
what I'm saying but you got some of them
breaking the law and knowing what the
consequence it might be behind it
because of what's going on the hardest
police brutality
you know what I've seen is there's a lot
of black communities where for different
reasons they were they were kept down
they're not they're poorly educated very
few opportunities for them to to make a
substantial income to support their
families themselves the whites kind of
liked it that way or at least some of
the whites liked it that way in his in
our history and eventually that comes
back to snap you in the butt because you
can't keep any race any person down for
too long eventually they're going to
react and revolt
and that's maybe what we're seeing now
is that the black community feels like
they've been down for so long no oh yeah
that's the way they feel like they've
been down ever since slavery be honest
with you
slavery segregation there could be train
set Yugi's still going on today but when
segregation came about we had a little
more freedom the blacks we had a little
more freedom and we could exercise our
freedom if we wanted to some wanted to
exercise their freedom go farther some
didn't don't worry we're a tannery about
none of that you know
but then when it come down to where the
situation it end they want to point the
finger the other way so we have been
down a while but we have been having the
opportunity to least get almost where we
want to be suggesting take advantage of
it yeah you know in all your decades of
living in the south what's the most
extreme racism that you've seen probably
when you were a kid I would I would
think Oh
in my childhood I'm gonna be honest with
you me I didn't I didn't have no problem
and I didn't I didn't see much of a
problem at that time I guess maybe I
wasn't looking at it - in order to
notice it but I never had problem of
another race doing me and treat me any
kind of way I ain't never had that
problem
you know when education change we went
to the school along with the others you
know and I ain't never had no problem
not in school they're not after school
I'm talking about me I don't know about
nobody else as a kid you were segregated
huh as a kid you were segregated in
school well one has a kid I mean
segregating me that we was given more
freedom more rights to be able to go
further in our life do things that we
could do once before but uh coming up as
a little child I didn't ever seen
nothing that was so drastic and Shawn
racism you know I didn't see men like
that
and I never had nothin like that to
happen to me never nothing like riding
in the back of the bus something like
that I never had none of that a spirit
under that you know III can see I I can
say that I was blessed because you know
I know there others that had many
problems and I had no you know I mean I
so far that's undercover
I might have been you know might have
been racism on the cover like if I go
apply for a job and they give the job to
somebody else when they know that I was
more qualified for the job well I can't
see it not knowing it because I don't
know if that happened to me so for job
wise you know but in everything else I
ain't never had no problem and in your
community in your congregation do you
think people fit your congregation is
100% african-american yeah and do they
feel kept down or or just do they feel
like they're being cheated in any way
to tell you I never had one of my
members come to me with a problem of
racism like for example what them took
place with their police brutality I
never had a member to come to me and
discussing that to me and how they feel
about it and everything never so my
members when something going down and it
if they're not right they use it to me
don't make no fuss about it
you don't see no you know are you
optimistic for the future for our
country
yeah if I can help my seat with that oh
well I couldn't tell you right now but I
think give it a few years I'd know so
give it a few years see where it's going
and it heart is going where it's going
and or did I have some kind of better
idea you know that's an interesting time
in our country right now man yes sitios
we you know right now I don't like I
said I don't believe at this point it's
gonna get better right now I don't
believe you know cuz it proved that was
proved on on other day one got killed in
a protester all throughout countries
then about a week later another one got
here like protesting and do no good
see that's what I'm saying it on me hey
you know I say that it's not enough
discipline on the police force they did
a little too easygoing with them
policeman's they've got to be made known
to them when they do wrong they're gonna
pay for their own if they're gonna pay
for it but when you good must slap on
the wrist
oh man then make next one think that
they can get away with it too and
there's all kinds of repercussions with
with society and with minority
minorities after that yeah yeah so we
all we all have to be very careful so
it's yes it's sad but uh I believe in
the Bible I'm a Bible believer the Word
of God and everything that help taking
place on this earth the Bible really
speaks of it a lot of things we just say
don't have no control over its going to
have to be fulfilled just gonna have to
be you know but we got to deal with it
all right Alfred thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts you welcome good
luck with your with your congregation
and everything that's going on in your
life oh thank you sir thank you
you